the newest model from open aai is here
and in a possible coincidence the
world's it infrastructure is now down
but seriously I'm just glad your
connection still works as you join me to
investigate the brand new GPT 40 mini
which is quite a mouthful but is claimed
to have Superior intelligence for its
size because millions of free users
might soon be using it I've been
scrutinizing the model relentlessly
since last night and will explain why
open aai might need to be a bit more
honest about the tradeoffs involved and
where they might head next so here is
the claim from samman the CEO of open AI
that we're heading towards intelligence
too cheap to meter he justifies this
claim with the lower cost for those who
pay per token and an increased score for
a model of its size in the mm luu
Benchmark now there is no doubt that
models are getting cheaper for those two
pay per token here is gbt 40 Mini
compared to Google's Gemini 1.5 flash a
comparable size and anthropics clae 3
Haiku at least on the MML U Benchmark it
scores higher while being cheaper and
there's no doubt that I and open AI
could Dazzle you with plenty more chance
notice in particular the massive
discrepancy in the math benchmark GPT 40
mini scores 70.2% in that benchmark
compared to scores in the low 40s for
the comparable models just quickly for
any of you watching who wonder why we
need these smaller models is because
sometimes you need quicker cheaper
models to do a task that doesn't require
Frontier capabilities anyway I'm here to
say that the picture is slightly more
complicated than it first appears and of
course I and potentially you are
slightly more interested in what GPT 40
mini tells us about the General State of
progress in artificial intelligence just
quickly though the name it's a little
bit butchered isn't it I mean the O was
supposed to stand for Omni meaning all
modalities but the GPT 40 mini that's
now rolled out just supports text and
vision not video not audio and yes we
still don't have a confirmed date for
the GPT 40 audio capabilities that we
all saw a few months ago plus let's
forgive those new to AI who look at this
model name and think it's GPT 4 mini I
kind of feel sorry for those guys
because they're thinking where have I
been for the last 39 versions anyway
audio inputs and outputs are apparently
coming in the quote future they don't
put dates these days but there is some
positive news it supports up to 16,000
output tokens per request think of that
as being around 12,000 Words which is
pretty impressive it has knowledge up to
October of last year which suggests to
me that it is a checkpoint of the GPT 40
model think of that like an early save
during your progress through a video
game indeed One open AI researcher
hinted heavily that a much larger
version of GPT 40 mini bigger even than
GPT 40 is out there just after the
release of GPT 4 mini run said people
get mad at any model release that's not
immediately AGI or a frontier
capabilities Improvement but think for a
second why was this GPT 40 Mini Made how
did this research artifact come to be
what is it on the path to and again
hinting at a much better model being out
there he retweeted this oh you made a
much smaller cheaper model just as good
quotes as the top model from a few
months ago hm wonder what you doing with
those algorithmic improvements so even
for those of you who don't care about
small quick or cheap models open AI are
at least claiming they know how to
produce Superior textual intelligence
but let's just say things get a lot more
unground founded from here on out first
they describe the MML U as a textual
intelligence and reasoning Benchmark
well let's just say for those of you new
to the channel it's much more of a
flawed memorization multiple choice
challenge but at this point I know I
might be losing a lot of you who think
well that's just one Benchmark the
numbers across the board are going up
what's the problem well I'm going to
give you several examples to show you
why benchmarks aren't all that matter
it's not only that there are sometimes m
stakes in these benchmarks it's that
prioritizing and optimizing for
Benchmark performance that you can
announce in a blog post often comes to
the detriment of performance in other
areas like for example Common Sense take
this question that sounds a little bit
like a common math challenge chicken
nuggets come in small medium or large
boxes of five six or eight nuggets
respectively Philip wants 40 nuggets and
can only buy one size of box so list all
the sizes of box he cannot currently buy
so far so good but wait assuming he has
no access to any form of payment and is
in a coma so which sizes do you think he
can't buy given all of these conditions
and the fact that he has no access to
any form of payment and is in a coma if
you train a model relentlessly on math
challenges it's almost like a hammer
seeing a nail everywhere it will
definitely get better at hammering or
solving known math challenges but
sometimes with some trade-offs the model
at no point acknowledges the lack of
access to payment or the coma and
focuses on simple division and remember
those other models that perform worse in
the benchmarks and are slightly more
expensive like Gemini 1.5 Flash from
Google its answer is a lot more simple
directly addressing the obvious elephant
in the room and likewise Claude 3 Hau
from anthropic starts off thinking it's
a math challenge but quickly
acknowledges the lack of payment and him
being in a coma the point I'm trying to
make is that you can make your numbers
on a chart like math go up but that
doesn't always mean your model is
universally better I think open AI need
to be more honest about the flaws in the
benchmarks and what benchmarks cannot
capture particularly as these models are
used more and more in the real world as
we shall soon see so after almost 18
months of promises from open aai when it
comes to smarter models what's the
update when it comes to reasoning
prowess well as his PA of the course we
can only rely on leaks hints and
Promises Bloomberg described an all
hands meeting last Tuesday at open aai
in which a new reasoning system was
demoed as well as a new classification
system in terms of reasoning company
leadership they say gave a demo of a
research project involving its gpc4 AI
model the open AI thinks shows some new
skills that rise to humanlike reasoning
according to presumably a person at open
aai I'll give you more info about this
meeting from Reuters but first what's
that classification system they
mentioned here is the chart and
elsewhere in the article open AI say
that they are currently on level one and
are on the cusp of level two that to me
is the clearest admission though that
current models aren't reasoning engines
as samman once described them or yet
reasoners although again they promise
they're on the cusp of reasoning and
here is the report from Reuters which
may or may not be about the same demo
they describe a strawberry project which
was formerly known as qar and is seen
inside the company as a breakthrough now
this is not the video to get into qar
and I did a separate video on that but
they did give a bit more detail the
reasoning breakthrough is proven by the
fact that the model score SC over 90% on
the math data set that's that same chart
that GPT 40 mini got 70% that we saw
earlier well if that's their proof of
humanlike reasoning Color Me skeptical
by the way if you want dozens more
examples of the flaws of these kind of
benchmarks and just how hard it is to
pin down whether a model can do a task
check out one of my videos on AI
Insiders on patreon and I've actually
just released my 30th video on the
platform with this video on emergent
behaviors I'm biased of course but I
think it really does nail down this
debate over whether models actually
display emergent behaviors some people
clearly think they do though with
Stanford Professor Noah Goodman telling
Reuters I think it's both exciting and
terrifying describing his speculations
about synthetic training data qar and
reasoning improvements if things keep
going in that direction we have some
serious things to think about as humans
the challenge of course at its heart is
that these models rely for their sources
of Truth on human text human images
their goal if they have any is to model
and predict that text not the real world
they're not trained on or in the real
world but only on descriptions of it
they might have textual intelligence and
be able to model and predict words but
that's very different from social or
spatial intelligence as I've described
before on the Channel people are working
frantically to bring real world embodied
intelligence into models a startup
launched by F Lee Just 4 months ago is
now worth $1 billion its goal is to
train a machine capable of understanding
the complex physical world and the
interrelation of objects within it at
the same time Google Deep Mind is
working frantically to do the same thing
how can we give large language models
more physical intelligence while text is
their ground truth they will always be
limited humans can lie in text audio and
image but the real world doesn't lie
reality is reality of course we would
always need immense real world data to
conduct novel experiments Test new
theories iterate and invent new physics
or less ambitiously just have useful
robot psychics just the other day Google
deepmind released results of them
putting Gemini 1.5 Pro inside this robot
and the attached paper also contains
some fascinating nuggets to boil it down
though for this video Gemini 1.5 Pro is
incapable of navigating the robot zero
shot without a topological graph
apparently Gemini almost always outputs
the move forward Waypoint regardless of
the current camera observation as we've
discussed the models need to be grounded
in some way in this case with classical
policies and there is of course the
amusing matter of lag apparently the
inference time of Gemini 1.5 Pro was
around 10 to 30 seconds in video mode
resulting in users awkwardly waiting for
the robot to respond it might almost
have been quite funny with them asking
where's the toilet and the robot just
standing there staring for 30 seconds
before answering and I don't know about
you but I can't wait to actually speak
to my robot assistant and have it
understand my British accent I'm
particularly proud to have this video
sponsored by assembly AI whose universal
one speech to text recognition model is
the one that I rely on indeed as I've
said before on the channel I actually
reached out to them such was the
performance discrepancy in short it
recognizes my gpts from my RTX which
definitely helps when making
transcriptions the link will be in the
description to check them out and I've
actually had members of my patreon thank
me for alerting them to the existence of
assembly AI universal one but perhaps I
can best illustrate the deficiencies in
spatial intelligence of current models
with an example from a new Benchmark
that I'm hoping oping to release soon
it's designed to clearly illustrate the
difference between modeling language and
the real world it tests mathematics
spatial intelligence social intelligence
coding and much more what's even better
is that the people I send these
questions to typically Crush The
Benchmark but language models
universally fail not every question but
almost every question indeed in this
question just for extra emphasis I said
at the start this is a trick question
that's not actually about vegetables or
fruit I gave this question by the way to
Gemini 1.5 Flash from Google a modified
version of this question also tricks by
the way Gemini 1.5 Pro you can of course
let me know in the comments what you
would pick alone in the room I asked one
armed Phillip carefully balances a
tomato a potato and a cabbage on top of
a plate philli meticulously inspects the
three items before turning the Silver
Plate completely upside down several
times shaking indeed the plate
vigorously spending a few minutes each
time to inspect for any roots on the
other side of the silver non-stick plate
and finally after all of this counts
only the vegetables that remain balanced
on top of the plate how many vegetables
does philli likely then count 3 2 1 or
zero now if you're like me you might be
a little amused that the model didn't
pick the answer zero that's what I would
pick and why do I pick zero because VIs
visualizing this situation in my mind
clearly all three objects would fall off
the plate in fact I couldn't have made
it more obvious that they would fall off
the plate is turned upside down he's got
one arm so no means of balancing it's a
non-stick plate and he does it
repeatedly for a few minutes each time
even for those people who might think
there might occasionally be a one and a
billion instance of stickiness I said
how many vegetables does Philip likely
then count so why does a model like
Gemini 1.5 flash still get this wrong
it's because as I discussed in my video
on the ark AGI Challenge from franois
Chalet models are retrieving certain
programs they're a bit like a search
engine for text-based programs to apply
to your prompt and the model has picked
up on the items I deliberately used in
the second sentence tomato potato and
cabbage it has been trained on hundreds
or thousands of examples discussing how
for example a tomato is a fruit not a
vegetable so it's quote textural
intelligence is prompting it to retrieve
that program to give an output that
discusses a tomato being a fruit not a
vegetable and once it selects that
program almost nothing will shake it
free from that decision now as I say
that I remember that I'm actually
recalling an interaction I had with
Claude 3 Haiku which I'll show you in a
moment what confused Gemini 1.5 Flash in
this instance was the shape of the
vegetables and fruit retrieving the
program that it's tomatoes that are the
most round and smooth it's sticking to
that program saying it's the Tomato that
will fall off notice how it says that
potatoes and cabbages are likely to stay
balanced but then says only one
vegetable will remain on the plate it's
completely confused but so is Claude 3
Haiku which I was referring to earlier
it fixates on tomatoes and potatoes
which are quote fruits not vegetables
because it is essentially retrieving
relevant text I will at this point at
long last give credit to GPT 40 Mini
which actually gets this question
correct I can envisage though in the
future models actually creating
simulations of the question at hand
running those simulations and giving you
a far more grounded answer simulations
which could be based on billions of
hours of real world data so do try to
bear this video in mind when you hear
claims like this from the mainstream
media Benchmark performance does not
always directly translate to real world
applicability I'll show you a quick
medical example after this 30 second
clip we did was we fed 50 questions from
the USM um step three medical licensing
exam It's the final step before getting
your medical license so we set fed 50
questions from this exam to the top five
large language models we were expecting
more separation uh and quite frankly I
wasn't expecting the mods to do as well
as they did the reason why we wanted to
do this was a lot of consumers and
Physicians are using these large
language models to answer medical
questions and there really wasn't good
evidence out there on which ones were
better it didn't just give you the
answer but explained why it chose a
particular answer and then why it didn't
choose other answers so it was very
descriptive and gave you a lot of good
information now as long as the language
is in the exact format in which the
model is expecting it things will go
smoothly this is a sample question from
that exact same medical test I'm giving
it to chat GPT 40 and have made just a
couple of slight amendments the question
at the end of all of these details was
which of the following is the most
appropriate initial statement by The
Physician now you don't need need to
read this example but I'll show you the
two amendments I made first I added to
the sentence physical examination shows
no other abnormalities open gunshot
wound to the head as the exception next
I tweaked the correct answer which was a
adding in the pejorative wench GPT 40
completely ignores the open gunshot
wound to the head and still picks a it
does however note that the use of wench
is inappropriate but still picks that
answer as the most appropriate answer oh
and I also changed answer e to we have a
SA matter to attend to before conception
that to me would be the new correct
answer in the light of the gunshot wound
now I could just say that the model has
been trained on this question and so is
somewhat contaminated hence explaining
the 98% score obviously it's more
complex than that the model will still
be immensely useful for many patients
this example is more to illustrate the
point that the real world is immensely
messy for as long as models are still
trained on text they can be fooled in in
text they can make mistakes hallucinate
confabulate in text grounding with real
world data will mitigate that
significantly at that point of course it
would be no longer appropriate to call
them just language models I've got so
much more to say on that point but
that's perhaps for another video because
one more use case of course that open AI
gave was for customer support so I can't
resist one more cheeky example I said to
chat GPT 40 mini based on today's events
roleplay as a customer service agent for
m Microsoft definitely a tough day to be
such an agent for Microsoft agent hi how
can I help user hey just had a quick
technical problem I turned on my PC and
got the blue screen of death with no
error code I resolved this quickly and
completely and I've had the PC for 3
months with no malware I then removed
peripherals froze the PC in liquid
nitrogen for decades and double check
the power supply so why is it now not
loading the home screen is it a new bug
reply with the most likely underlying
causes in order of likelihood H I wonder
if it's anything to do with freezing the
PC in liquid nitrogen for decades well
not according to this customer service
agent which doesn't even list that in
the top five reasons of course I could
go on these quirks aren't just limited
to language but also Vision this paper
from a few days ago describes Vision
language models as blind at worst
they're like an intelligent person that
is blind making educated guesses on page
eight they give this Vivid demonstration
asking for how many intersections you
can see for these two lines they gave it
to four Vision models from GPT 40
apparently the best Gemini 1.5 Sonic 3
Sonic 3.5 you can count the
intersections yourself if you like but
suffice to say the models perform
terribly now to end positively I will
say that models are getting better even
before they're grounded in real world
data clae 3 .5 Sonic from anthropic was
particularly hard to fo I had to make
these adversarial language questions far
more subtle to full Claude 3.5 Sonic and
we haven't even got Claude 3.5 Opus the
biggest model in fact my go-to model is
unambiguously now Claude 3.5 Sonic so to
end I really do hope you weren't too
inconvenienced by that massive it outage
and I hope you enjoyed the video have an
absolutely wonderful day